string theory is a version of quantum
mechanics that is quantum mechanics is
is less a completely specific theory
than a class of theories theories that
involve this principle of superposition
that we were just talking about theories
whose fundamental equations of motion
have a certain particular kind of
mathematical structure so on and so
forth so one can enumerate five or six
basic principles of quantum mechanics
okay and these principles allow for a
way that rather wide range of more
specific claims of exactly what
elementary systems the world is made of
and and so on so forth so string theory
is is one version of quantum mechanics
one version of a quantum theory it's a
theory whose fundamental ontological
entities aren't particles but these
one-dimensional objects these strings
and and that fundamental ontology looks
promising for all sorts of reasons
especially in regard to attempt to make
coherent quantum theory of gravitation
and so on and so forth but in the
context of our discussion here it's one
version of a quantum theory it shares
all of the weird properties that we were
just talking about the measurement
problem the principle of superposition
so on and so forth with every other
quantum theory and these foundational
problems especially the measurement
problem come up in string theory in
exactly the same way as they come up in
older versions of quantum mechanics
we need we need to smack particles
together you know this is this is of
course a one doesn't want to anticipate
what's going to happen and maybe
tomorrow somebody's going to figure out
some much more clever and much cheaper
experimental method of distinguishing
between string Theory's and other
quantum theories we have but insofar as
we know at the moment the only way of
getting a handle on whether or not
string theory is true is going to be the
very brute force very expensive project
of building these huge accelerators
they're going to smack particles
together with such intensity that is
that is with energies with energies
reminiscent of the energies that
particles had in the in the very early
milliseconds of the life of the universe
where the predictions of string theory
are going to differ from the predictions
of other interesting quantum theories
that we have on the table so it's going
to be a matter of doing those it's going
to be a matter of doing those
experiments
no even that I mean I mean there may be
the evidence that we would get even from
that as far as I understand the matter
would still be rather indirect although
there are things that could emerge from
those experiments which which would be a
more comfortable fit for certain string
theories than them then for other
theories that we have on the table but
even that evidence is is going to be is
going to be rather indirect um you know
what most people say nowadays is look
the best evidence we have for string
theory is that there is a phenomenon of
gravitation and we don't know anyway
besides string theory of making
gravitation compatible with quantum
mechanics